maintenant de notre enquête sur la
situation au cambodge dans un pays
traumatisé par la guerre et les suites
du génocide perpétré par le régime de
pol pot de 75 à 78
la formation est un objectif prioritaire
en particulier dans le secteur de la
santé un exemple avant polpot il y avait
au cambodge 450 médecins
en 1979 il n'en restait que 25
aujourd'hui pour faire face à des
besoins énormes le pays bénéficie de
l'aide d'organismes internationaux
c'est le cas par exemple de l'hôpital de
takéo près de la frontière vietnamienne
une région d'ailleurs où les paul petit
sont encore très actifs
le reportage de philippe borrel et kim
vim dans cet hôpital tenu par la croix
rouge suisse ont fait beaucoup de
traumatologie ici la priorité des
chirurgiens consiste à éviter au maximum
les amputations suite à des accidents
par mines ou par balles principe
consiste à l'immobilisation d'une
fracture compliquée comme dans ce cas la
part d ombre au chat j'ai fait à
distance du foyer de fracture et par là
nous obtenons un système de dison demi
mobilisation de fixation de la fracture
qui permet soit la phase est sceptique
d'avancer tranquillement et de
pratiquement 2 c'est anne et en même
temps après la consolidation de lance de
se faire normalement il ne s'agit pas de
faire du secourisme mais de mettre en
oeuvre un réel programme de formation
générale en particulier la chirurgie
pour assurer le fonctionnement et
développer la formation cette équipe
suisse qui fonctionnent depuis septembre
86 s'était fait une laborantine est une
sage femme infirmière chef ont porté
leur nombre de 3 5 mètres et
d'uniformité les soins infirmiers au
niveau de chaque secteur
par exemple si un potage de sonde
urinaire faut que tout le monde le fasse
pareil moi je fournis tout le même
matériel dans chaque secteur
je monte la technique la même manière on
essaie d'uniformiser les soins parce que
ça existait pas chacun fait un petit peu
comme on voulait
en tout cas le but c'est ça c'est que
après ceux des bruits elle même éthique
elle continue les soins avec assez de
qualité qui si on peut dire en tout cas
d'asphyxié de propreté dans le domaine
de la santé comme dans les autres
priorités restent à la formation
fait encourageant depuis 79 ce sont plus
de 1200 médecins infirmières et
dentistes qui sont déjà opérationnels